when i saw you do that nirvana tribute
holy [ __ ] i said this guy's talented
i read that you went to courtney love to
get her blessing to do that
well we went to
kurt's daughter
and um it was it's important to me
because i love kurt
so much and he's been such an
inspiration
to me musically i could never want to
offend anybody by trying to show support
so i just wanted to make sure everything
was okay
and um it was okay and we we raised
money for a good cause and
we got to play some [ __ ] some of the
most [ __ ] epic songs ever on your
face it says stay away
that's in honor of kurt cobain right
stay away
yes sir was that the first face tattoo
you ever got
no sir
my first face tattoo was
a smiley face with x eyes
i was like [ __ ] it looks like
marshmallow dude
he's just supposed to be a drunk guy
i was like oh my god i like marshmallow
he's such a sweet guy but i'm like i
don't want to face tattoo of you
well i was scared shitless of you
because you know when i was growing up i
mean i got tattoos but if you got a face
tattoo
it either meant you were in a gang you
know with the teardrop thing and you
killed the dude or it meant you're out
of your [ __ ] mind the word was that a
tattoo artist would never
ever do somebody's face when you went
for the first one did the guy sit down
like an intervention and go dude i'm a
tattoo artist i can't do this to you or
is he just go let's go for it
we were both sober so right cool it all
went normal
as normal as that cat yeah yeah it went
normal it was like you're freaking
the first one were you freaking out the
first time you did it because like
whenever i get a new tattoo and i look
at it i go oh [ __ ] it's so glaringly big
it looks much bigger on me
did you have any of those misgivings
no sir
i think everything that i have
takes me back to a time in my life
and um
whether i like it or not
those times happen
and this is my story and this is how i
look
and this is who i am you know